if it's okay by you we come continue in
English because it's better than my bad
Swedish anyway my bad English is better
than my bad Swedish I understand you
better
perhaps in English and in the region no
probably fully your reads your research
shows that that Neanderthals had sex
with humans this is this is very
surprising to me anyway because I
thought they were living in different
millenniums oh well they actually
overlaps and the undertones are our very
closest relatives they are like ten
times closer to us and chimpanzees are
and they lived until about thirty or
forty thousand years ago and they
actually met modern humans when they
came out of Africa and encountered them
in Europe and Western Asia and I'm not
surprised we had sex with him I think we
have sex with almost everything we
encounter in our history the surprising
thing to me was that one actually had
babies together and that those babies
obviously we integrated into modern
human society and came to contribute to
people today genetically so so how do
you imagine these dates how did they I
mean they were bigger than us one day
they were stopped you're more muscular
yes so they were having sex with us not
the opposite of tungsten I tend to say
how we think about this say more about
our own fascinations and what is it
happening today how much how much of a
Neanderthal are we I mean now I mean
well it depends on who you're if your
roots are in Europe and Asia completely
somewhere between one and two percent of
your DNA that
that comes from Neanderthals if you're
from Africa you have no Neanderthal
contribution because they were never in
the under tools in Africa so so we would
be Neanderthals a part part part a part
say but would it differ from person to
person wouldn't would well if for
example one of your parents is from
Africa you will have about half all the
contribution from the undertones right
okay so and it won't have parents from
us except I know probably all of us
actually have yes so we're all like
quite much Neanderthals yes and how does
that I will that where can we see time
you can I see it on my hands can I see
it on my on my legs or we base or is it
like we begin to learn a little bit
about that now from studies that come
from using the Neanderthal genome that
we have determined so it turns out that
some genes involved in immune defense
for example how we deal with bacteria
and viruses that attack us some variants
of such genes come from Neanderthals to
us there are variants that cause risk to
get type 2 diabetes the type of diabetes
you get at the older age that come from
Neanderthals and there is actually in
Tibet Tibetans who live at high altitude
on the Tibetan Plateau or gene variants
that allows you to live at such low
oxygen tensions there come from a
relative on the undertones that we also
discovered from the dissidents so they
have actually to some extent have had
important influences on on people today
if we if we if we lived on earth at the
same time
why did humans win in the other that is
a good question that no one real has a
answer to it has to do something to do
with how modern humans behaved of course
because it's not only the Neanderthals
that disappeared other forms of humans
in Asia disappeared you know this little
hobbits Homo floresiensis in
neasha it disappeared the last 30
thousand years of our history actually
unique because it's just one form of
humans around in the world today it has
to do with our behavior and some form
but what that is is not at all clear and
and how far back in history can I go
well so these techniques you now develop
the sequence in the Undertown genome
we're now trying to apply them to older
things then we've gone back to 400,000
years ago to cite in Spain we were sort
of ancestors of Neanderthals were
beginning to get some DNA now so I would
say half a million years perhaps
approaching a million years or so in the
future or we'll be able to go you can
you can find you can find DNA that's
almost a million years old well so what
we have done with human ancestors is is
400,000 in the permafrost where things
have been permanently frozen when I gone
back seven hundred thousand years animal
remains no dinosaurs tell me no dinosaur
no dinosaurs so no the Jurassic Park is
just that's out in my opinion
that won't happen are you disappointed
now no okay I everybody sort of knew
that I think but it was it you know
dresser park was a book that written by
Michael Crichton and it was just
something that he more or less came up
with it was a good interesting theory
and very entertaining but it's pretty
old you know 65 million years and older
what when when you were at the dinner
party what do people ask you I think one
thing that's very often camera up and
make the little tired is this can be
bringing back can we clone in the
undertow because you can't you can't
really is it an in in your in your book
you you write about your father he was a
Nobel laureate and still you did not
grow up in in his shadow that's fair to
say
because you didn't see much yes a my
father met my mother when he was a
professor in London southern Sweden and
she was a student and technician in his
lab and then I was created and this was
in the 50s so my mom had to leave town
and I was born in Stockholm man and
after while my mother actually became a
professor here at the Karolinska
Institute so he would show up on
Saturdays for a few hours when his
family thought he was working in the lab
so that was a you were you were a secret
child yes such a secret yes how how was
that for you I grew into it you know
from my very earliest memories this was
how it was that my father had another
family had another son very same age as
Howie and they didn't know about us
though so I met my brother only when my
father was dying in that 2004 you had
quite imeem you you had an interesting
life yourself but made it very you were
in a similar situation one can say but
made a very different choice
I do you mean when I met my wife Linda
yes she was already married and of
course it was a crisis but we are
actually managed to return that crisis
with her then-husband also so we even
moved into the same house or alive and
live together you and her husband and
yes and Harris now he lives two blocks
away
this is like the Swedish movie until
someone's okay maybe haven't seen that
one
no but so so we you were sort of when
you decided to tell him to confront the
situation was that I had that to do with
your father's life I think many things
in my life probably have to do whether
they're so my father's double life and
said I don't want to live like that so
both this case and the fact that I'm
attracted both to men and women sexually
for example things that I have tried to
be open and and straightforward about
yes you were living with the man before
right no yes you've you've become quite
a famous scientist and your research on
the Neanderthals has as has been world
news is it I I wonder if the most
surprising place they were interested in
your research that was Playboy wasn't it
mmm vaguely but I don't know I didn't I
didn't read that piece okay I just heard
about me because um well since it has to
do with sex I guess they were interested
and I thought this is my one chance to
be in Playboy magazine
so how's the peace out I think it was
surprisingly serious actually the
pictures that are component were not so
serious but the textures of you know it
was pictures of Neanderthal women and
they were not seriously because they
didn't really have the D on the towel
the women I suppose exactly yes how did
they depict them rather unattractive I
must say what to be honest weren't they
quite on the strata for I don't know I
don't know don't we have seen them right
or did they look different than we think
in the under house I think the only
thing we know is that we were quite
robust that say the muscle attachments
are quite big there must have been quite
muscular and then it depends if you find
that attractive or not I'm very hairy
are you into muscle attachment are we
trying am I the only one trying to work
out sometimes as long as it's not yoga
you're saying not yoga but meditation
but is it they they would they they
would be stronger than us in many senses
on average they would be strongest
Sophia
if the Neanderthals were living among us
today mm-hmm how would they manage they
would probably manage pretty well but it
would probably be some differences
probably in the cognitive area of some
sort because it's after all true
Neanderthals lived for three four
hundred thousand years and there are
stone tools at the beginning of their
history in the end of their history were
very similar
we have existed little over a hundred
thousand years I think we all agree that
our culture and technology are very
different today from hundred thousand
years ago so we could make them pay pay
quite a lot for our smartphones maybe
because they wouldn't really invent
something maybe or maybe it has
something to do with our sociality the
fact that we are many people who
speculate
that we spend you know a sir first third
of our lives to learn what previous
generations have learned and then we add
to that that we have this enormous drive
to sort of communicate and transmit
knowledge especially to our children and
that that maybe you can it may not be
that they are less smart individually
and we are but we have this enormous
sociality we still kill in the same
barbaric and primitive way unfortunately
or even more organized are you saying
that possibly it's the parenting style
the innate parenting social behavior yes
the people who have that theory that you
have this sort of enormous at least if
you compare ourselves to the great apes
sort of striking how the parents do not
teach at all the children of chimpanzees
sit for hundreds of hours trying to
learn cracking nuts next to their mother
and you see these videos and as a human
is a sure show rich kids social and they
don't but we're a large part of what we
do when we interact with our children's
is to trust me knowledge correct their
behavior many societies institutionalize
this with schools and universities you
have an enormous emphasis on
transmitting knowledge interesting
that's really Salta thank you so much
for being here what did you have - he
made me exercise which really it's just
a terrible terrible thing I couldn't
believe it I who love to sit and talk
was forced to exercise